look at this Twitter the Great Purge has
begun Twitter uses a report losing
thousands of followers as Elon Musk
formerly takes over the platform and
sets to work on bot cleaning he says he
hasn't changed it's a you know like the
content moderation but take a look at
this Kate Smith says wow I lost a few
hundred followers overnight welcome to
Twitter Elon people are saying I lost
followers one person with the Ukrainian
flag in their profile I lost 50
followers
yeah unit I think said it before I'll
say it again
Twitter was propping up fake accounts to
make it look like the left was more
prominent than they were because the
right is more prominent and they were
Banning people on the right and Shadow
Banning them to make it seem like they
were less prominent they put their thumb
on the scale and this is so important
when you talk about politicians you talk
about their staff you talk about the
decisions that happen in Washington they
see Twitter as really what's the
Viewpoint of the vast majority of people
their constituents what's public what's
the Public's you know view on things but
it's a completely manipulated you know
audience pool I mean if it was a
congressional district it'd be like a d
plus 70. it's not something that exists
in the real world and it's all about the
perception that they're creating the
illusion they're creating and it's not
just the likes it's not just the follows
it's even the comments I mean you see
those those memes that go around where
it's all the same comment that's being
shared every time a major news cycle
hits and I'm glad he's going after it
it's also noticeable it's these
left-wing accounts claiming they're
losing followers which were Bots a few
weeks ago it was right-wing accounts
because I mean they lost followers were
real people they're saying it's people
quitting the platform in protest just so
what because the 4 000 followers a bunch
of conservatives joining the platform I
don't believe it because Twitter
recommends leftist accounts not writing
account first leftists they'll never
follow through on their threats to quit
they never move to Canada for example so
I doubt that they actually you know are
quitting Twitter right now so it's
certainly Bots that was something he
brought up and that was something that
came up you know when the evaluation
talks when they were first you know in
in talks to buy it was the bot issue I
mean that that's a fundamental issue it
could be that Elon and melee went after
the Bots first thing he did his first
task yeah yeah and so you know I'll say
maybe I want to see some changes faster
than he can go about it maybe Elon is
like the Bots got to go first and
advertisers are on board with that if we
want to go back to the finite because
they want real legitimate clean you know
metrics they don't want Bots or maybe
just to investigate to see what was
going on to see what the algorithm
really was to see how it was being
manipulated to see who was being
punished for what I I think there needs
to be a long investigation into what is
essentially a very potentially very
illegal activities with election
interfering done by Twitter so that
that's a very serious uh you know
accusation but but only someone who just
acquired a company is going to be
looking into that right now as right
speaking and we have to give them more
credit I do agree with you he's coming
into a company where the workforce that
exists is largely hostile I hate him
hates him he needs to fire 70 I think he
could probably fire 90 he is in a good
position that he could bring over some
loyal you know staff and support from
you know Tesla some of his Engineers
there Etc but it is going to take a
period of time just from a logistical
technical perspective to dig into this
and actually find out what's going on
behind the scenes how it can be
rectified how it can be and how do you
reduce it guys guys he's not going to
endear himself to the employees after he
just fired ligma Johnson you know
Johnson was asking for it how is this
ligma Johnson is on local news and a
very serious person this is real this is
really his name yes I think it was like
no no it was two guys it was like Rahul
ligma and Daniel Johnson were they they
got fired there were controls they
showed up to Twitter HQ with boxes that
is awesome I think they're gonna get
hired they thought they got fired
automatically it turns out you're
looking for a job I mean honestly if
you're a free software developer and you
want to get involved keep your eyes on
Twitter because he's going to be hiring
or it can just be a community project
he's going to be fired he's going to be
opening up a lot of solutions but the
thing is I don't think Twitter needs I
don't know whether they have 5 000
employees I mean if you're running a
free software decentralized Network you
need the world's Community to be
involved I want and you don't need to
pay them there's so many
can I show you this guys parag agrawal's
salary was 30.4 million in 2021. Ned
Seagal was 18.9 million Vijaya was 17
million Sean Edgar his compensation was
unclear he was the one who had to be
escorted out of the building which is
really interesting so uh let us as a
former CEO Sarah personnet was handed a
11.2 million as part of musk's house
clearance I want you to think about
30.4 million dollars and I'd like to ask
you what does what do you do with that
money what do you do with it I was going
to say what they did for it but no I
mean he's working a full-time job which
is very like he runs Twitter I know
being the CEO it's a very it's a high
level job of a very large company it's
just insane to me that these people like
couldn't get an edit button done in a
year but they were given 30 million
dollars the pay wasn't based on the
merits or the financials or anything
quantitative it was based on loyalty to
the regime and the regime's you know
Doctrine and what they were trying to
push to this platform and the social
engineering they wanted to use the
platform for and they were you know only
willing participants in that so they
were paid handsomely for doing a job
well done but it's not based on any you
know basic profit or loss model of a
traditional business it's based on
loyalty to the regime and that's why
this gentleman uh will be spending that
30 million somehow I have no idea though
30 million dollars to not be able to get
an edit button done in a year
that's just it's it's incredible I don't
think people truly understand what 30
million dollars means he wouldn't be
able to spend that if he tried wasn't
there like a dozen real engine I'm
making the numbers up but there was an
extremely small number of real engineers
and the entire structure of the
workforce was like a reverse pyramid
where it was those 12 supporting this
massive bloated you know pension scheme
at Twitter effectively and it was like
these few Engineers that were doing all
the work and everything else was just
you know corporate fluff and councils
and committees and you know diversity
leaders whatever it is yeah yeah I don't
think the hardware was the was the
majority of the people there are
probably people that are like how do we
handle the crowd kind of people right
trust and safety it's like so orwellian
it's all like an extension of HR it's
all just these these positions that
exist to perpetuate their own positions
they're not actually fundamentally doing
any real work I will say like you said I
don't know maybe there were incredible
developers across the board there was a
meme that came out that said uh you know
uh musk fires half of Twitter replaces
it with one hard-working Indian engineer
yeah yeah that's basically what it is he
could do the job of 3200 people right
yep exactly that sounds about right it's
all emo pushing jobs you know they send
an email they're gonna Circle back and
uh that that concludes the day all right
guys the thing about uh the compensation
that really gets me is that
I would be willing to bet
a substantial sum myself that you the
average viewer could do his job
not kidding
what knowledge does he have where he was
like it was mismanaged it was managed so
poorly the company was struggling it was
basically failing the this is just there
there is an elite class in this planet
it's always been the case they do
nothing they get everything but they
think it's unmerited in uh 2018 there
were roughly 4 000 Twitter employees
three years later 2021 or four years
later I guess there were 75 someone from
4 000 to 7 500. almost doubled the
amount now that's the user growth which
I think if you factor out Bots I don't
know what it is but it's probably
stagnant if not you know a downward
Trend but at least if you factor out
Bots which may not be possible all right
let's find out yeah people are pointing
out that Kanye's Twitter account is back
and um Elon pointed out that's an
automatic thing has nothing to do with
him you know oh it was like one of those
seven day things or whatever right and
so it was a kind of just turned back on
you should just take credit I just you
know it really is shocking and and it's
unfortunate I I would be willing to bet
additionally
that if I took that 30 million dollars
in one year 30 and gave it to a random
viewer of this show they would build
something more substantial more
historical and better than anything he
did that's just I really can't stand
Silicon Valley and and that machine
crony capitalist BS just I I despise it
so much it's an incentive structure for
loyalty you keep these guys operating
against their own company's best
interests because they know the payout
will be greater than whatever else they
could get through normal channels and
and I guess he got 60 million dollars to
get fired
parag yeah you got 60 million I think
someone in fact check it real quick well
in a way I think golden parachute was uh
60 million I was wondering what what
Elon would do I'm glad that he gave them
payouts I mean I don't think you can
ethically just say like goodbye now
everything that you were earning is set
to zero so but that's a lot of money my
man ethically 60 million million bucks
uh let's see I got this uh the total
value they say in Guardian was 120
million dollars in Golden parachutes
do they break it down
uh here we go what is it uh
no okay 8.4 tiger wall doesn't sound
right this level goes back to the FED
30. 4.8 million to vajayagade why would
she get more than the CEO that seems
strange
whatever I think she's been there longer
she's a woman
well she's been there longer so maybe
that's it but I just it's just so crazy
man I'm looking at the user growth the
numbers from 2018 they had 335 million
monthly active users but then two years
later they had 330. so I mean the
actually down five million so the staff
went up and the users went down that's
right that's a great it's a great setup
yeah the staff went from yeah almost
went from 4 000 to 5500 while the daily
user it pays to be the thought police
you know so when you're centering speech
when you're going after people for
political ideas and expression and act
like you're fighting the Germans during
the 1930s you got to be paid a lot of
money to to play pretend for that long
for for that much for for that much of a
for that big of a circumstance so I'm
not crazy of an act exactly yeah you
know and and you know you gotta pay for
private security if you're in Silicon
Valley you know a lot of crazy people
out there running around with hammers
and deranged individuals and people
throwing poop at you and people you know
syringes people giving themselves the
the vaccine in the streets all the time
so I want to see rumble's headquarters
because I'm thinking about Twitter's HQ
was very lavish yeah I got a tour of
them is it all like Bachelor style
apartment
it it it it it it's surreal because it
looks like a cartel house like right on
the water it's like it's it's huge it's
crispy treated you with like a scotch
and a cigar and he was like where's the
Lamborghini I'm like this looks like a
scene out of Scarface it really does I
don't know I'm like where where's the
you know where's the rifle was it that's
better than a modernist soulless
building in Silicon Valley with their
cafeteria and absolutely perks and it's
not that big it's but it it that's what
I'm wondering how many floors two floors
oh see that's modest you don't we didn't
have a huge I mean that is a massive
amount of overhead not that many rooms
either you just don't need it not with
social media man you don't need big
buildings it's it's a it's all about
servers and server placement which
ideally will have that stuff in orbit
because if we do take some sort of
asteroid uh contact that we're going to
need to preserve our our data and our
knowledge yeah but Ian the problem is
um how do you dissipate the heat in
outer space well on on Big Data Centers
you would hit it with laser like laser
cooling laser cooling like if you hit
something with a laser it should move
heat that way move heat where off along
with the laser like the laser will carry
the heat I mean I see I see what you're
saying so the laser goes through it and
then actually transfers energy out
correct if if we could do direct thermal
uh conversion into light and then beam
it away that would work that's that
would be crazy I'm glad you're my friend
that's a cool idea it's pretty cool I
mean for right now yeah actually that's
interesting but the servers are going to
generate heat we can try and recapture
heat but it's got to go somewhere
because the ambient heat we can't
control perfectly the efficiency
wouldn't be there yeah I should just
write things on Stone just go back the
servers operate by a guy reading the
code and typing in the ones and zeros
manually yeah yeah let's see yeah in 27
years you'll get this tweet out Chris
pavlovski CEO of Rumble and Elon have
been I don't know if they the two of
them directly have been in talks but
Chris reached out to him on Twitter
about a month ago I was like hey you
want to get involved because I'm a big
fan and Elon was like all right and then
now I hear they're working on like
because Chris is a server guy elon's a
satellite guy
Twitter needs a video component Twitter
needs something that that could either
be a tick tock or another Periscope or
another Vine they need that they don't
have that what if you really what if
Elon does succeed with with X and
Twitter becomes a place where you've got
a wallet uses crypto you can post videos
you can write stories you can make
tweets like it really becomes what Mark
Zuckerberg was hoping Facebook would
become the American WeChat and then I'm
gonna be critical of it and skeptical of
it because of how powerful and
all-encompassing it will be no as of
right now I'm optimistic when I see Bill
Gates and other establishment figures
attacking him but but when it becomes
too mainstream that's when I'm gonna
have questions well no one thought that
Myspace was going to fail or even
Snapchat and now it looks like Facebook
the platform itself is pretty much going
nowhere so who knows we'll get a
revitalization story at a time if I was
if I was a billionaire I would do what I
would call The parag agrawal Challenge
and I would give 30 million dollars to a
random person for for an investment
project obviously there's rules you
don't just get the money it would be an
investment not income it would be we
credit we create a company we put 30
million in It Go
and then we would see at the end of one
year what we have
it would be I think it would be
hilarious because like you could take
your average like contractor and they'd
be like oh I built a bunch of houses
like wow houses oh that's really amazing
parag what did you do in one year well I
was running Twitter and we could get an
edit button done it's like uh-huh I'm
sure he was doing something you know
what I mean but based on that project
Veritas video where the guy is like I
work four hours a week or something like
that right I really doubt any of them
are doing anything wow yeah you want
people that are committed to 40 plus
hours a week at least because it's about
organization at that level if you have
30 million like I could pay you 30
million but if you're only working eight
hours a week and there's no other
employees well you've seen those viral
Tick Tock videos right the girl walking
around like here's my day in the office
yoga it's really stressful red wine on
tap right so here's here's the secret
investors ask people they say
um ask you a question
if tomorrow you woke up and you had a
million dollars in the bank account cash
clean ready it was it was legitimate
deposit what would you do
what would you do Gavin
I would just buy property you'd buy
property yeah that's not a terrible
answer they're not making any more land
what about you Ian what would you do I
think I would buy a house at this moment
yeah it depends at this interest rate
are you crazy although I hear the
housing markets cash it's like cash
purchase uh what would you do if you
woke if you woke up and you had a
million dollars just in cash buy a whole
bunch of employees and expand operations
Buy employees like slaves no no but
that's Take It Outside
no no that's not I said the box your
guys's answer would never get you an
investment oh yeah I'm not looking oh oh
you want it oh yeah well yeah it doesn't
matter if you think you're getting
investment or not the question I mean I
could pay four people 100 Grand okay but
here's what people are looking for
they're looking for someone who
naturally wants to expand operations not
someone who needs to be told to do it so
if you said I'd buy a house they go
that's really cool nice meeting you and
if they went to a homeless guy and he
goes like I'd love to start a company
now just we're gonna make bird houses
and I'm gonna hire 100 people and have
the biggest birdhouse back you're tired
here we'll give you the money it could
be 72 000 a month for server space on
AWS while I'm paying 60 grand for nine
employees three of which will be
working for the six others two people
will be resp you know that kind of thing
but they're like oh God yes plug it in
but you need to understand this that
most people be like oh well I didn't
know you meant if I was going to do a
business I don't I mean what's your
first priority and you guys clearly said
property not a bad answer because
property is an investment most people
say like I go to Hawaii I take my family
out those people will never see a dime
from an investor but what what what so
even even with what we're doing here at
timcast the biggest challenge is
Personnel is finding people who want to
work on something not people who want a
job people who want a job tend to just
you know quite quit do the bare minimum
so when you're trying to invest in
someone to give them a substantial
amount of money you want to go to
someone and say if you had a million
dollars what'd you do it's like oh man
you know I've always wanted to launch my
own comic book distribution Network and
if I just had the capital we'd get it
going but I've already got the books I
just need to figure out how to get to
these you're hired here's the money have
fun good luck what do you find is the
bulk of cost when you're running
operations labor almost like labor
specifically uh in-house labor out of
House labor it's all the same Labor's
labor people are the most expensive
thing by far yeah yeah but I mean do you
do you end up spending 20 15 of the of
the cost on like outsourced labor like
legal stuff like that marketing things
like that what do you what do you mean I
just wonder just just in general like if
you spend it mostly on in-house
employees or if you of course of course
most of it's an in-house I mean we have
a lot of contractors and then we have
legal and then we have construction and
then we have external marketing and PR
there's a lot of stuff that we don't do
in-house because it doesn't make sense
to do and uh most of the cost is like an
employee working for the company you
prefer to do that I mean in-house it's
not so much prefer as just like
it's it's more like if there's a a wavy
field you know let's say this table was
wavy and you poured water on it the
water would pull in the lowest point you
know what I mean it's it's not like I'm
I'm saying we should do contract labor
or something it's like that's how it's
done I'm not gonna hire a lawyer to work
for this company you know what I mean
I'm gonna contract a legal a law firm
who can handle it specialization yeah
yeah like the people we need to hire the
people need to be here all the time
specifically like a video producer an
audio engineer but like Vice head
in-house counsel you know they they had
a room with like two or three lawyers in
it they were really really big maybe
we'll get to that point you know but uh
you know yeah anyway my point ultimately
about the cash stuff is
I look at a lot of the people in Silicon
Valley and other people these companies
and they should not be getting paid what
they're getting paid because they don't
care about the product they don't care
about the growth they don't care about
the mission they don't believe in Merit
they believe in like I deserve to be
here and then they do nothing and so it
burns to the ground it's a broader
problem in Corporate America where you
see these these compensation packages
are so out of whack with what they
actually deliver and you know they make
excuses and they talk about the scale of
things Etc but at the end of the day you
know it it still is very much out of
whack when you look at what you
mentioned before the growth in terms of
staff and employees and the and the the
decrease in actual users I mean there's
a like a 40 increase in staff with no
nominal growth here's here's a secret if
you want to be rich go hang out with
rich people that's it goodbye I'll tell
you why
the in like the Palisades in Brentwood
in California and L.A you know these
places yeah beautiful these are the
places where if you're just friends with
one of these wealthy Hollywood Elites
you can be like you know I sell this
fancy lotion it's a hundred dollars a
bottle they'll say oh I'd love some and
then it's it's Jergens in a little
bottle and and this is the way it works
I've known people who who are like oh I
make jewelry and I'm like how much do
you make per year it's only a couple
hundred thousand per year and I'm like
for making Joy yeah but I have a very
select clientele of Hollywood Elite it's
like okay because you know Rich Hamptons
too because you're friends with rich
people and they want to buy from you
they just have money and give it to you
you're rich there you go there's a whole
social like class absolutely between the
Hamptons and Hollywood whatever that
that feed off of that usually you know
they fall into like the wine mom you
know category of in terms of
demographics it's unfortunate when
people turn to alcohol when they get
bored like they beat the game and they
just start getting drunk every night the
only day difference on average in my
opinion maybe not not necessarily but
there is a there is a there's a fine
line between someone with a carpet a a
sheet thrown on the ground with a bunch
of jewelry strung about it and they're
sitting there smiling at you saying one
dollar necklaces and some you know yoga
wine Aunt who is making three hundred
thousand dollars a year selling
necklaces to select clientele in the
Palisades it's just who you know a four
thousand dollar haircut because you're
worth it exactly and then they're able
to write that off on their taxes I don't
think you could write off haircuts on
your taxes thank God depending on your
industry
yeah entertainment so like Hollywood can
and this is the craziest thing if you're
if you're an actor in Hollywood all that
cosmetic stuff is a business expense and
I mean to be honest it kind of is it's
legitimate yeah you need to look a
certain way and whatever but it I I have
I have hung out with people who have
told me their jobs are just like oh you
know I I sell this that or otherwise and
I'm like and you make that money half a
million dollars something they're like
well of course I get 20 Commission on
all the products and my clients are all
very wealthy and I'm like
it's like a Royal Court for like these
you know aristocratives you got the jobs
you got a few people exactly Luke you
mentioned that you were you would expand
operations are you talking about for we
are change yeah and then uh just looking
at Solutions I think
um providing food that's not poison uh
is is a good Big Industry that I think
has a lot of potential to also get into
that I would want to get into that I'm
kind of looking into getting into uh and
and helping people as much as they can
so like selling like Health product
health food uh maybe not even just
health food maybe just normal regular
food you know yeah without seed oil
without high fructose corn syrup seed
oils and and all the you know forever
chemicals and microplastics and other
things that that just destroy Humanity
it has a green label on it and it says
it's healthy what are you trying to tell
me no no no no you're wrong
propagandized let's put little styrofoam
cubes in in a plastic wrap and then put
the ingredients list you know on it and
then people won't they won't know the
difference anyway you know what I mean
you'd see a guy eating it
didn't they do an experiment where they
made a Rice Krispie with like sawdust
just a small amount of sawdust and
wanted to see if people could tell and
they couldn't it's basically equivalent
what they do to mostly have you looked
at parmesan cheese from the supermarket
oh yeah one of the ingredients is
cellulose yeah it's it might as well be
cardboard right it's indigestible plant
matter well yeah and they they talk
about oh it's it's like we have a
society where you're constantly having
to work out just to be the bare minimum
in terms of healthy you go to Europe you
look back in time you know the caloric
intake hasn't gone up it's it's the
quality of the food we're putting in is
trash and then we wonder why we're more
unhealthy so here we talked about this
the other day I went on uh we had Seth
weather's on he said I need to eat more
protein I said I ate like 100 grams in
one days you need 150 and I was like do
I and then I checked like a government
website it said 70 grams but it's
actually be eating 400 to 500 carbs and
then I was just thinking to myself I
couldn't eat that many carbs if I tried
well they also said eggs were bad they
said butter was bad they said everything
bad meat was bad it's like it's it's all
nuts whatever the government says don't
do the opposite do what tradition tells
you a tradition says eat a lot of meat
eggs butter let me let me tell you you
know those outright bars we have yeah
those have 24 grams of carbs in it so I
have to eat like what 20 of them to get
the 500 carbs they I couldn't I could
barely eat one of those protein but
Grant has protein in them but if I ate
if I ate 20 of them that's too much oh
my gosh 20 of them are you insane they
want you fat childless and on a really
manipulated Twitter that's their yeah
yeah yep and so I've been eating uh so I
I probably do need more protein to be
honest I I skate a lot exercise a lot
but it's just insane that that's what
people are told to eat
the whole system just seems completely
broken to me and we waste so much time
talking about health and exercise
instead of putting into other productive
things it's like we're so focused on the
bare minimum not being you know an obese
morbidly obese person you know these are
things 100 years ago you really have to
deal with and I'm not saying they had to
go out and hunt or gather and you know
hunt their food we had a balance you
know as recently as the 1970s you could
look at the charts it it backs it up but
we just have so much time and energy
wasted now into health food and just
returning to a normal seat like you said
that's not even Health Food it's just
normal food normal food that my grandma
used to eat that that we don't get to
eat right now because of a number of
different factors uh mono cropping is
another horrible element but but more
importantly you don't even need to look
at the science of the data look at the
photos look at the people a couple
decades ago look at the people now it's
terrifying whenever you go to like a
beach or a public park or a theme park
you look around and if you start paying
attention you're like holy freaking cow
there is a biological warfare being
committed on everyone mostly in this
country though because you go to other
countries it's not nearly as bad you see
that photo from the 50s where everyone's
just fit looking yeah so weird yeah you
didn't go to gyms they didn't they
didn't count the calories now Disney is
doing that fat chick film right where
it's like you can be morbidly obese but
it's okay it's sort of it feels like
we're dancing around a Renaissance but
if not for the the overweight the
Obesity crisis what's all these
distractions because we have to relearn
all these basic things we used to know
and be able to do innately you know just
be healthy now it's like this is an
active thing we have to do to be healthy
they call it organic food organic means
carbon based all food is organic right
but but they created a special word for
what food is supposed to be I love it
it's like organic food means like food
right so we should actually we should we
should change this chemical food and
food right so it's like I got milk is it
chemical milk or is it milk altered it's
chemical well languages that's all
language that's language language
Warfare I mean even look at schools it's
like public school it's a state school
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there